willkommen zurück zu „Understanding Quantum Information and Computation", mein Name ist John Wattrus und ich bin der technische
Bildungsdirektor bei IBM Quantum. Dies ist die 11. Lektion der Reihe und die dritte Lektion in der
dritten Einheit, die sich mit der allgemeinen Formulierung von Quanteninformation befasst. Diese Lektion handelt von Messungen, die eine
Schnittstelle zwischen Quanten- und klassischer Information darstellen. Wenn eine Messung an einem System durchgeführt wird, während es sich in einem
Quantenzustand befindet, wird klassische Information extrahiert, die etwas über diesen Quantenzustand enthüllt und ihn im Allgemeinen verändert oder
dabei zerstört. In einer vereinfachten Formulierung der Quanteninformation, die
in der ersten Einheit der Reihe besprochen wurde, beschränken wir unsere Aufmerksamkeit typischerweise auf projektive Messungen, einschließlich der
einfachsten Art von Messung – Standardbasismessungen. Es ist jedoch möglich, den Begriff einer Messung zu verallgemeinern,
und das erweist sich als recht nützlich. In dieser Lektion sprechen wir über Messungen in voller Allgemeinheit,
einschließlich ihrer mathematischen Beschreibung und wie sie in die allgemeine Formulierung von Quanten-
information passen. Am Ende der Lektion werden wir uns auch ein paar grundlegende Konzepte ansehen, die mit Messungen zusammenhängen, nämlich Quantenzustand-
Diskriminierung und Quantenzustandstomographie. Also, fangen wir an. Hier ist eine Übersicht der
Lektion. Wie wir es oft tun, beginnen wir mit den Grundlagen, einschließlich ein paar verschiedener, aber äquivalenter Weisen, wie wir
Messungen in mathematischen Begriffen beschreiben können. Insbesondere können wir Messungen durch Sammlungen von Matrizen beschreiben,
und wir können sie auch als Kanäle beschreiben, worauf ich in der vorherigen Lektion hingewiesen habe. Wir werden auch partielle
Messungen besprechen, also Messungen, die nur an einem Teil eines größeren zusammengesetzten
Systems durchgeführt werden. Dann kommen wir zum Neymark-Theorem, einem grundlegenden Satz über Messungen, der im Wesentlichen
besagt, dass allgemeine Messungen immer auf eine einfache Weise implementiert werden können, die an die Stinespring-
Darstellungen von Kanälen erinnert. Kurz gesagt können allgemeine Messungen immer implementiert werden, indem man zunächst ein
initialisiertes Hilfsraumsystem einführt, dann eine unitäre Operation durchführt und schließlich eine Standardbasis-
messung am Hilfsraumsystem vornimmt. Das lässt sich ziemlich einfach beweisen, und wir werden sehen, wie das geht, und
wir werden auch sehen, wie das mit sogenannten nicht-destruktiven Messungen zusammenhängt, die ich abschließend im letzten Teil der
Lektion beschreiben werde. Wir besprechen Quantenzustand-Diskriminierung und Quantenzustandstomographie. Wir beginnen mit den mathematischen
Beschreibungen von Messungen. Messungen bieten uns eine Schnittstelle zwischen Quanten- und
klassischer Information. Wenn eine Messung an einem System durchgeführt wird, während es sich in einem Quantenzustand befindet, wird klassische Information
über diesen Quantenzustand extrahiert. Darüber hinaus wird der Quantenzustand im Allgemeinen verändert oder möglicherweise
vollständig zerstört. Zunächst konzentrieren wir uns auf sogenannte destruktive Messungen, bei denen
ein Quantenzustand eingeht und nur klassische Information herauskommt, es also keine Spezifikation des
Post-Mess-Quantenzustands des gemessenen Systems gibt. Intuitiv gesprochen können wir uns vorstellen, dass eine destruktive Messung
das gemessene System zerstört, sodass sein Zustand nach der Messung nicht
spezifiziert ist. Das bedeutet nicht buchstäblich, dass physikalische Geräte notwendigerweise zerstört werden – es ist nur eine mathematische
Beschreibung, und sie ist sehr nützlich, weil sie hilft, die Dinge einfach zu halten und sich auf die wesentlichen
mathematischen Aspekte von Messungen zu konzentrieren. Es gibt insbesondere zwei äquivalente Wege, destruktive
Messungen zu beschreiben, die ich während der Übersicht der Lektion erwähnt habe. Eine Möglichkeit, eine destruktive
Messung zu beschreiben, ist durch eine Sammlung von Matrizen, wobei wir insbesondere eine Matrix für jedes mögliche Mess-
ergebnis haben. Eine zweite Möglichkeit, eine destruktive Messung zu beschreiben, ist durch einen Kanal, bei dem
der Eingang der Zustand des gemessenen Systems ist und der Ausgang immer eine diagonale Dichtematrix ist, die wir
als Beschreibung einer Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung über die möglichen klassischen Mess-
ergebnisse interpretieren können. Die beiden Beschreibungen sind äquivalent, und das ist ziemlich nützlich, weil es uns erlaubt, diejenige Beschreibung zu wählen, die in einer
gegebenen Situation bequemer ist. Wir werden auch über nicht-destruktive Messungen sprechen, bei denen zusätzlich zu einem klassischen Mess-
ergebnis auch der Post-Mess-Quantenzustand des gemessenen Systems
spezifiziert ist. Nicht-destruktive Messungen sind wichtig und kommen häufig vor, aber in gewissem Sinne sind sie
weniger grundlegend als destruktive Messungen – in mathematischer Hinsicht. Genauer gesagt stellt sich heraus, dass
nicht-destruktive Messungen immer als Kompositionen von Kanälen und destruktiven Messungen beschrieben werden können, und
wir werden sehen, wie das ein bisschen später in der Lektion funktioniert. Schauen wir uns jetzt an, wie Messungen – also destruktive
Messungen – als Sammlungen von Matrizen beschrieben werden können. In dieser Diskussion nehmen wir an, dass X ein System ist, das
gemessen wird, und der Einfachheit halber machen wir ein paar Annahmen. Erstens nehmen wir an, dass die
klassische Zustandsmenge von X aus den ganzen Zahlen von 0 bis n minus eins besteht, für eine positive ganze Zahl n, und die möglichen
Messergebnisse sind die ganzen Zahlen von 0 bis M minus eins, ebenfalls für eine positive ganze Zahl M. Es muss
keine Beziehung zwischen den Zahlen n und M geben – beide sind beliebige positive ganze Zahlen, und natürlich könnten wir
diese Mengen durch beliebige klassische Zustandsmengen ersetzen, wenn wir das möchten. Erinnern wir uns zunächst daran, wie projektive
Messungen funktionieren, über die wir zum ersten Mal in der dritten Lektion der Reihe gesprochen haben. Da wir annehmen, dass
die Messergebnisse die ganzen Zahlen von 0 bis n minus eins sind, beschreiben wir eine projektive Messung durch eine Sammlung
von Projektionen Pi 0 bis Pi M minus eins, die zur Einheitsmatrix aufsummieren, und diese Matrizen haben alle Zeilen und
Spalten, die den klassischen Zuständen von X entsprechen – also sind das alles n-mal-n-
Matrizen. Wenn sich x in einem Quantenzustand befindet, der durch einen Quantenzustandsvektor s beschrieben wird, dann erscheint jedes mögliche Mess-
ergebnis a mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit, die gleich der euklidischen Norm im Quadrat von Pi a multipliziert
mit dem Vektor s ist. Die euklidische Norm im Quadrat eines Vektors ist gleich dem inneren Produkt dieses
Vektors mit sich selbst, sodass wir den auf dem Bildschirm gezeigten Ausdruck erhalten, den wir ein
wenig vereinfachen können, indem wir die Tatsache nutzen, dass Pi a eine Projektion ist, sodass die Multiplikation mit sich selbst nichts
bewirkt. Schließlich können wir den erhaltenen Ausdruck auf eine etwas andere Weise umschreiben, indem wir die zyklische Eigenschaft
der Spur verwenden, wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. Und falls nicht klar ist, warum wir den Ausdruck so schreiben wollen –
die kurze Antwort ist, dass wir verstehen möchten, wie projektive Messungen für Dichte-
Matrizen, und insbesondere gilt durch Linearität: Wenn der Zustand von X durch eine Dichtematrix Rho beschrieben wird, anstatt
durch einen Quantenzustandsvektor, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das Ergebnis a auftritt, gleich der Spur der Projektion
Pi a mal der Dichtematrix Rho – das muss so sein, weil wir, wie gesehen haben,
eine Dichtematrix immer als gewichteten Durchschnitt reiner Zustände betrachten können, und wenn wir die
entsprechenden Wahrscheinlichkeiten mitteln, erhalten wir diesen Ausdruck, weil die Spur eine lineare Funktion ist – das ist also der Ausdruck, nach dem wir
suchen, und wir können die Dinge ein wenig vereinfachen, um uns auf die Dichte-
matrizen zu konzentrieren. Der eigentliche Zweck dabei ist übrigens, einen Bezugspunkt zu dem herzustellen, was wir bereits gelernt haben,
und zu zeigen, dass diese Beschreibung projektiver Messungen tatsächlich ein Spezialfall einer allgemeineren Beschreibung von Messungen ist, die wir
gleich kennenlernen werden. Was ich jetzt also tun werde, ist diese Beschreibung, wie projektive Messungen für Dichtematrizen funktionieren,
durch die Beschreibung für allgemeine Messungen zu ersetzen, damit wir die Beziehung verstehen können – und hier ist
sie: Eine allgemeine Messung – nicht notwendigerweise eine projektive Messung – wird durch eine Sammlung positiv semidefiniter
Matrizen P 0 bis PM minus eins beschrieben, die sich zur Einheitsmatrix addieren. Wenn diese Messung an X durchgeführt wird, während es sich
in einem durch eine Dichtematrix Rho beschriebenen Zustand befindet, dann tritt jedes Ergebnis a mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit auf, die gleich der Spur von PA mal
Rho ist. Kurz gesagt: Das Einzige, was sich geändert hat, ist, dass wir die Bedingung an diese Matrizen gelockert haben – insbesondere müssen die Matrizen
keine Projektionsmatrizen sein, sie müssen nur positiv semidefinit sein. Entsprechend habe ich den Buchstaben Pi durch den Buchstaben P ersetzt,
weil Pi ein konventioneller Name für eine Projektion ist, während ich den Buchstaben P für positiv semidefinite
Matrizen verwende. Das ist übrigens eine Verallgemeinerung der Beschreibung, die wir für projektive Messungen hatten, weil Projektionsmatrizen immer positiv
semidefinit sind und tatsächlich alternativ als positiv semidefinite Matrizen definiert werden können, deren Eigenwerte
nur null oder eins sein können. Wir können beobachten, dass diese Definition
Sinn ergibt, da wir für die Ergebniswahrscheinlichkeiten immer einen Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor erhalten, und zwar auf folgende
Weise: Erstens sind diese Zahlen, die ich als Ergebniswahrscheinlichkeiten bezeichne, immer nicht-negative reelle Zahlen – das liegt
daran, dass sowohl PA als auch Rho positiv semidefinit sind und die Spur des Produkts zweier positiv semidefiniter
Matrizen immer eine nicht-negative reelle Zahl ist. Das überlasse ich dir zum Nachdenken, warum das
so ist. Und zweitens müssen sich die Zahlen zu eins summieren, weil die Spur linear ist und
die Matrizen P 0 bis PN minus eins zur Einheitsmatrix summieren müssen und Dichtematrizen die Spur eins haben.
Also werden die Ergebniswahrscheinlichkeiten immer einen Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor bilden, unabhängig davon, mit welcher Dichtematrix Rho wir begonnen haben.
Schauen wir uns nun einige Beispiele an. Ich habe bereits erwähnt, dass
projektive Messungen ein Spezialfall allgemeiner Messungen sind, weil Projektionen immer positiv semidefinit sind.
Aber es ist schön, einfach anzufangen – beginnen wir also mit einer Standardbasismessung eines qubit. Wir können eine Standardbasismessung
eines qubit durch zwei Matrizen P 0 und P1 darstellen, die wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt definiert sind: P 0 ist Ket-null Bra-null, und P1 ist Ket-eins
Bra-eins. Beide sind positiv semidefinite Matrizen und tatsächlich Projektionen, und sie summieren sich offensichtlich zur
Einheitsmatrix, beschreiben also zusammen eine Messung. Wenn wir diese Messung auf ein qubit anwenden,
das sich in einem durch eine Dichtematrix Rho beschriebenen Zustand befindet, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das Ergebnis null auftritt, die Spur von P 0 mal Rho,
und die Wahrscheinlichkeit für das Ergebnis eins ist die Spur von P1 mal Rho. Durch die zyklische Eigenschaft der Spur erhalten wir
die zwei Diagonaleinträge von Rho, wie erwartet. Hier ist ein weiteres Beispiel, bei dem
die Matrizen diesmal keine Projektionen sind. Sie sind jedoch positiv semidefinit und sind zufällig auch Dichte-
matrizen – aber das ist nicht wichtig. Was wichtig ist: Sie summieren sich zur Einheitsmatrix, beschreiben also zusammen eine
Messung. Wir können sehen, was passiert, wenn diese Messung an einem qubit im Plus-Zustand durchgeführt wird, zum Beispiel einfach um
zu sehen, wie es für ein Beispiel eines Zustands funktioniert. Eine Berechnung der Wahrscheinlichkeiten ist auf dem
Bildschirm gezeigt. Beachte insbesondere, dass obwohl der Plus-Zustand ein reiner Zustand ist und wir diesen Zustand durch den Quantenzustandsvektor Ket-Plus darstellen können,
wir die Dichtematrixdarstellung dieses Zustands – nämlich Ket-Plus Bra-Plus – in die Formeln einsetzen müssen, um die
Wahrscheinlichkeiten zu erhalten. Ich möchte auch anmerken, dass, weil wir über eine destruktive Messung sprechen, es keine
Angabe des Quantenzustands dieses qubit nach der Messung gibt. Wir haben also nur eine Angabe der Ergebnis-
wahrscheinlichkeiten. Hier ist ein abschließendes Beispiel für jetzt, und es ist ein ziemlich interessantes. Wieder ist es eine Messung eines
einzelnen qubit, und um es zu beschreiben, beginnen wir mit der Definition von vier Quantenzustandsvektoren, bekannt als die tetraedralen
Zustände. Der Grund, warum sie tetraedrische Zustände heißen, ist, dass sie den vier Ecken eines
regelmäßigen Tetraeders entsprechen, das in die Bloch-Sphäre einbeschrieben ist. Zur Klarstellung: Wenn wir sagen, dass es sich um ein regelmäßiges Tetraeder handelt,
meinen wir einen vierseitigen Körper, bei dem jede Fläche ein gleichseitiges Dreieck ist. Es gibt also eine perfekte Symmetrie: Jede
Kante hat dieselbe Länge und der gleiche Winkel bildet sich zwischen je zwei benachbarten
Kanten. Jetzt können wir eine interessante Messung mit vier möglichen Ergebnissen definieren, wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. In Worten können wir unsere
Matrizen als die Dichtematrixdarstellungen dieser Zustände dividiert durch zwei wählen. Diese sind definitiv positiv
semidefinit, weil es sich um Dichtematrizen dividiert durch zwei handelt. Und man könnte die Arithmetik durchführen, um zu überprüfen,
dass sie sich tatsächlich zur Einheitsmatrix summieren. Aber eine andere Möglichkeit, das zu sehen, ist, über die Symmetrie nachzudenken: Wenn wir diese vier Zustände mitteln,
erhalten wir den vollständig gemischten Zustand, der sich im Zentrum der Bloch-Sphäre befindet. Aber weil wir
jeden durch zwei statt durch vier dividieren, erhalten wir das Doppelte des vollständig gemischten Zustands, was die Einheitsmatrix ist. Ich werde über
diese Messung jetzt nichts weiter sagen, außer zu beobachten, dass es keine projektive Messung ist, aber ein schönes Beispiel und
wir werden es später in der Lektion wieder begegnen. Eine andere Möglichkeit, allgemeine Messungen zu beschreiben, ist als Kanäle – so wie wir das jetzt
besprechen werden. Die Idee dabei ist, dass klassische probabilistische Zustände durch diagonale Dichtematrizen dargestellt werden können, und da
Messergebnisse klassisch sind, können wir Messungen als Kanäle betrachten, bei denen der Ausgang immer eine diagonale Dichte-
matrix ist, die das Messergebnis beschreibt. Schauen wir uns das etwas genauer an: Wenn wir
abstrakt über eine allgemeine Messung nachdenken, können wir diese Messung als einen Kanal Phi beschreiben. Das Eingabesystem für den Kanal ist
das System X, das gemessen wird, und das Ausgabesystem ist ein System Y, dessen klassische Zustände den
Messergebnissen entsprechen – wir nehmen an, dass das die ganzen Zahlen von 0 bis N minus eins für eine positive ganze Zahl sind.
M. Und weil Messergebnisse klassisch sind, verlangen wir, dass für jede Eingabe-Dichtematrix Rho für das System
X der Ausgang Phi von Rho eine diagonale Dichtematrix sein muss. Wenn wir zum Beispiel über einen
Standardbasismessung eines qubit und wenn wir über diese Messung als einen durch einen Kanal beschriebenen Prozess nachdenken, können wir sie so ausdrücken, wie hier auf dem Bildschirm zu sehen ist
Wenn die Eingangs-Dichtematrix rho ist, erhalten wir das Ergebnis null mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit gleich bra 0 rho ket 0
und wir erhalten das Ergebnis eins mit Wahrscheinlichkeit bra 1 rho ket 1, und wenn wir diese klassischen
Messergebnisse als Dichtematrizen ausdrücken, erhalten wir diesen Ausdruck für den entsprechenden Kanal, und es stellt sich heraus,
dass es sich um nichts anderes als den vollständig dephasierenden Kanal handelt, was mit der Idee übereinstimmt, dass der vollständig dephasierende
Kanal eine extreme Form der Dekohärenz darstellt, was verschiedene Bedeutungen haben kann, aber wenn ich diesen Begriff verwende, meine ich
die Tendenz, dass Quantenzustände klassisch werden, weil die Umgebung um das jeweilige System, über das wir
sprechen, in gewissem Sinne beobachtet, oder mit anderen Worten: misst
Messergebnisse können also als Kanäle beschrieben werden, wie ich gerade erläutert habe, aber das ist nicht nur eine Möglichkeit, sondern eine
Charakterisierung allgemeiner Messungen, und was ich damit meine, ist Folgendes: Natürlich gibt es Kanäle,
die keine Messungen darstellen, weil der Ausgang nicht immer eine diagonale Dichtematrix sein muss, aber wenn es der
Fall ist, dass der Ausgang eines Kanals immer eine diagonale Dichtematrix ist, unabhängig davon, welchen Eingangszustand rho wir wählen, dann ist es notwendigerweise möglich,
diesen Kanal in der auf dem Bildschirm gezeigten Form auszudrücken, für eine bestimmte Wahl einer Messung, also einer Sammlung von
positiv semidefiniten Matrizen, die zur Identität summieren, und das ist aus mehreren Gründen schön, unter anderem weil es
uns im Wesentlichen sagt, dass unsere Definition von Messungen als Sammlungen von Matrizen nichts
auslässt. Eine andere Möglichkeit, das zu sagen, ist, dass diese Art, Messungen als Kanäle zu betrachten, operational
oder vielleicht axiomatisch ist, in dem Sinne, dass sie erfasst, was eine Messung sein sollte, nämlich ein physikalischer Prozess, der
Quanteninformation in klassische Information umwandelt, und es stellt sich heraus, dass das vollständig äquivalent zu unserer ersten
Beschreibung von Messungen ist, die rein algebraisch ist. Ich werde den Beweis der Äquivalenz in diesem Video nicht durchgehen, aber er ist
nicht schwierig, und wenn du interessiert bist, findest du den Beweis im schriftlichen Material zur Lektion, das in der Video
Beschreibung verlinkt ist. Wir haben besprochen, was passiert, wenn eine allgemeine Messung an einem System in einem bestimmten Zustand durchgeführt wird,
zumindest für den Fall destruktiver Messungen. Als nächstes werden wir über Teilmessungen sprechen, also dass nur
ein Teil eines zusammengesetzten Systems gemessen wird. Um genau zu sein, nehmen wir an, dass wir ein Paar von Systemen XZ haben, die
gemeinsam in einem Zustand beschrieben durch eine Dichtematrix rho sind, und eine Messung, beschrieben durch eine Sammlung positiv semidefiniter Matrizen, die zur
Identität summieren, wird nur am System X durchgeführt. Natürlich führt das zu einem
Messergebnis, und weil wir über destruktive Messungen sprechen, können wir uns vorstellen, dass der Messprozess das System
X zerstört. Aber wir haben immer noch das System Z, um das wir uns kümmern müssen, und wir müssen verstehen, wie die Messung von X den
Zustand von Z beeinflusst. Sprechen wir zunächst über die Ergebnis
Wahrscheinlichkeiten. Da wir über eine Messung nur am System X sprechen, können die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für verschiedene
Ergebnisse nur vom Zustand von X allein abhängen, das heißt, sie können nur vom
reduzierten Zustand von X abhängen. Insbesondere ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit für ein bestimmtes Ergebnis a gegeben durch
dieselbe Formel wie zuvor, nämlich die Spur von PA mal dem reduzierten Zustand von X, den wir mit rho
subX bezeichnen. Der Zustand rho subX wird aus rho durch Ausspuren von Z gewonnen, sodass wir diese
Substitution vornehmen können, und obwohl es vielleicht nicht sofort offensichtlich ist, lässt sich der Ausdruck, den wir erhalten, alternativ so schreiben, wie
auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt: Es ist die Spur von PA tensoriert mit der Identitätsmatrix auf dem System Z mal
rho. Das ist eine Gleichheit, die es definitiv wert ist, etwas Zeit zur Überprüfung aufzuwenden. Es ist intuitiv – wir machen
gar nichts mit Z, daher ergibt es Sinn, dass die Identität auf Z so auftaucht. Es lässt sich aber auch algebraisch überprüfen,
und ich überlasse das dir, zusammen mit dem Vorschlag, zunächst den Fall zu betrachten, dass rho ein Tensorprodukt zweier Matrizen ist, und dann
Linearität zu nutzen, um daraus zu schließen, dass es für alle rho gelten muss. Ich möchte auch sagen, dass es nicht davon abhängt, dass PA
positiv semidefinit ist oder dass rho eine Dichtematrix ist. Das ist eine Gleichheit, die für beliebige Matrizen
an Stelle von PA und rho gelten würde, solange sie die richtigen Dimensionen haben, damit der Ausdruck einen
Sinn ergibt. Und jetzt schauen wir uns an, wie der Zustand von Z durch die Messung beeinflusst wird. Der natürliche Ansatz
meiner Meinung nach ist, die Messung als Kanal zu betrachten. Hier ist der Kanal, den wir unserer Messung zuordnen, und wir
denken darüber als einen Kanal vom System X zu einem neuen System Y nach, dessen klassische Zustände den Messergebnissen entsprechen. In dieser Formel
stellt Sigma einen Zustand des Systems X allein dar. Wenn wir diesen Kanal auf das
System X anwenden, während das Paar XZ im Zustand rho ist, erhalten wir die Dichtematrix, die wir hier sehen. Nimm dir
so viel Zeit, wie du brauchst, um das zu überprüfen, und mein Vorschlag ist wieder, zunächst den Fall zu betrachten, dass rho ein Tensor
Produkt zweier Matrizen ist, und dann Linearität zu nutzen. Nun haben wir diesen Zustandstyp gesehen,
bei dem das erste System klassisch und das zweite System quantenmechanisch ist, als Beispiel in der Dichtematrix
Lektion. Jedes a tritt mit einer bestimmten Wahrscheinlichkeit auf, und das ist die Spur des zweiten Tensorfaktors, also kannst du
dir diese zweiten Tensorfaktoren als Dichtematrizen vorstellen, die mit Wahrscheinlichkeiten multipliziert sind. Um den Zustand von
Z bedingt auf ein bestimmtes Messergebnis a zu erhalten, teilen wir einfach die Wahrscheinlichkeit heraus, oder mit anderen Worten: Wir
normalisieren den zweiten Tensorfaktor, indem wir ihn durch seine eigene Spur teilen. Zusammenfassend: Wenn wir eine
Messung an X durchführen, während das Paar XZ im Zustand rho ist, passiert Folgendes: Erstens tritt jedes Ergebnis a
mit Wahrscheinlichkeit gleich der Spur von PA tensoriert mit der Identität mal rho auf. Zweitens ist, bedingt auf
ein bestimmtes Messergebnis a, der Zustand von Z durch den auf dem Bildschirm gezeigten Ausdruck gegeben, was wir durch
Normalisieren der Matrix erhalten, die wir gerade eben gesehen haben, und das ist dasselbe wie das Teilen der Matrix durch die Wahrscheinlichkeit
für das Auftreten von a. Ich sollte erwähnen, dass das nur Sinn ergibt, wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit ungleich null ist, da wir sonst
durch null teilen würden. Aber das ist in Ordnung, denn wir müssen uns nicht um Dinge kümmern, die nicht vorkommen. In diesem Teil der
Lektion werden wir ein einfaches, aber grundlegendes Theorem über Messungen besprechen, bekannt als Neymar's
Theorem. Kurz gesagt besagt es, dass jede Messung so implementiert werden kann, wie die Abbildung auf dem Bildschirm
andeutet. In Worten ausgedrückt: Eine gegebene allgemeine Messung an einem System X kann auf folgende Weise implementiert werden:
Wir führen zunächst ein initialisiertes Arbeitsbereichssystem Y ein, dessen klassische Zustände die möglichen Messergebnisse sind, die wir als
0 bis n minus 1 nummeriert annehmen. Dann wird eine unitäre Operation U auf dem Paar durchgeführt
YX und dann wird eine Standardbasismessung an y durchgeführt, also ist hier im Grunde alles festgelegt,
außer der Wahl von U, und was das Theorem besagt, ist, dass es tatsächlich möglich ist, diese unitäre
Operation U so zu wählen, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für die verschiedenen Ergebnisse stets mit der gegebenen allgemeinen
Messung übereinstimmen. Schauen wir uns jetzt an, wie Neymars Theorem bewiesen wird – und es ist nicht schwer; wir müssen nur eine gute Wahl für
die unitäre Operation U treffen und überprüfen, dass sie funktioniert. Aber zuerst brauchen wir eine grundlegende Tatsache
aus der Matrizentheorie, nämlich dass es für jede positiv semidefinite Matrix P immer eine eindeutige positiv semidefinite
Matrix Q gibt, sodass Q² gleich P ist. Im Allgemeinen könnte es viele Matrizen geben, die quadriert P ergeben, aber
es gibt immer genau eine davon, die positiv semidefinit ist. Die Notation, die wir verwenden, um diese Matrix zu bezeichnen, ist die Quadratwurzel von
P, und so bezeichnen wir sie auch in Worten. Wenn du die Quadratwurzel von P für eine positiv
semidefinite Matrix P berechnen möchtest, kannst du das übrigens tun, indem du zunächst eine Spektralzerlegung von P berechnest und dann
jeden der Eigenwerte durch seine Quadratwurzel ersetzt und die Eigenvektoren unverändert lässt. Die Eigenwerte sind alle nicht-
negativ, sodass das sinnvoll ist, und es ist ziemlich leicht einzusehen, dass die Matrix, die wir erhalten, tatsächlich positiv semidefinit
ist und zu P quadriert. Die Tatsache, dass sie eindeutig ist, ist eine andere Sache; es ist nicht schwer,
das mithilfe einiger grundlegender Fakten über Matrizen zu beweisen, aber es ist gewissermaßen eine Abschweifung von der Lektion, und wir werden diesen Teil einfach
als gegeben hinnehmen. Und jetzt, da wir dieses Konzept zur Hand haben, ist es ziemlich einfach, eine
unitäre Operation U anzugeben, die funktioniert. Jede unitäre Matrix, die dem Muster entspricht, das auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird, wird tatsächlich
funktionieren. Die ersten n Spalten – wobei angenommen wird, dass X wie zuvor n klassische Zustände hat – werden durch Übereinanderstapeln der Quadratwurzeln der
Matrizen gebildet, die die Messung beschreiben, und die übrigen Spalten können beliebig sein –
es spielt keine Rolle, solange die gesamte Matrix unitär ist.
Und falls du übrigens eine Ähnlichkeit mit dem Zusammenhang zwischen Kraus- und Stinespring-Darstellungen von Kanälen bemerkst, ist das kein Zufall, und
tatsächlich ist das, was wir hier haben, im Wesentlichen ein Spezialfall davon, wobei unsere Kraus-Matrizen zufällig alle positiv
semidefinit sind. Es gibt also zwei Dinge, die wir überprüfen müssen: Das erste ist, dass diese Wahl von U tatsächlich funktioniert, und das
zweite ist, dass es möglich ist, die nicht angegebenen Spalten so zu wählen, dass U unitär wird. Fangen wir also mit dem ersten
an. Hier ist der Zustand, mit dem wir beginnen: Das untere System Y wird auf den Nullzustand initialisiert, während das obere System
im Zustand Rho beginnt, und dann führen wir U durch, was bedeutet, dass wir durch
U konjugieren. Wir können das alles in Form von Blockmatrizen ausdrücken, wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt: Wir haben U auf der linken Seite, U-Dagger auf der
rechten Seite und K-Null-Bra-Null tensoriell verknüpft mit Rho in der Mitte, was die Form hat, die wir hier sehen, mit Rho in der
oberen linken Ecke und Nullen überall sonst. Und wenn du dieses Produkt einen Moment lang betrachtest, wird deutlich, dass die
nicht angegebenen Einträge von U überhaupt keine Rolle spielen, da sie immer mit den Null-Einträgen dieser
Matrix in der Mitte multipliziert werden. Und wenn wir die Multiplikation durcharbeiten, erhalten wir diese
Matrix, die hier als Blockmatrix dargestellt ist, oder alternativ können wir sie in Dirac-Notation ausdrücken,
wie hier gezeigt. Das ist tatsächlich die praktischere Form für uns. Konzentrieren wir uns also auf diesen
Ausdruck, und der Einfachheit halber geben wir dieser Matrix, die eine Dichtematrix ist, den Namen
Sigma. Der letzte Schritt ist die Standardbasismessung an y. Berechnen wir also den reduzierten Zustand in y, und
das ist einfach, angesichts des Ausdrucks, den wir haben: Wir partialisieren X weg, was dem zweiten Tensor-
Faktor entspricht. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit für das Auftreten eines bestimmten Ergebnisses a ist also der Diagonaleintrag, der a entspricht. Wir können das
so schreiben, und es entspricht der Spur der Quadratwurzel von PA * Rho * der Quadrat-
wurzel von PA, und durch die zyklische Eigenschaft der Spur erhalten wir die Spur von PA * Rho,
was wir uns erhofft hatten. Die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für das Auftreten der verschiedenen Ergebnisse sind also korrekt und stimmen stets überein
mit der ursprünglichen Messung, mit der wir begonnen haben. Das zweite, was wir überprüfen müssen,
ist, dass es möglich ist, die nicht angegebenen Spalten von U so zu füllen, dass es
unitär wird. Das folgt aus der Tatsache, dass die ersten n Spalten – also diejenigen, die durch die Quadratwurzeln der Matrizen gebildet werden, welche die
Messung beschreiben – orthonormal sind, und das lässt sich ziemlich direkt überprüfen. Die relevanten Details sind hier
auf dem Bildschirm zu sehen. Mach also das Video auf Pause und nimm dir ein paar Momente, um darüber nachzudenken, wenn du möchtest. Aber wie ich zuvor angedeutet habe,
ist es eigentlich ein Spezialfall von etwas, dem wir in der vorherigen Lektion begegnet sind, und das ist der
Beweis. Bisher in der Lektion haben wir uns auf destruktive Messungen konzentriert, das heißt, es gibt keine Angabe des
Quantenzustands des gemessenen Systems nach der Messung. Bei einer nicht-destruktiven Messung hingegen gibt es
nicht nur ein klassisches Messergebnis, sondern auch einen Quantenzustand des gemessenen Systems nach der Messung, und wie
wir sehen werden, besteht ein natürlicher Zusammenhang mit Neymars Theorem. Es gibt tatsächlich verschiedene Möglichkeiten, nicht-destruktive
Messungen mathematisch zu formulieren, aber wir beginnen mit einer Formulierung, die im Grunde direkt aus Neymars
Theorem folgt. Betrachte eine allgemeine Messung – also eine destruktive –, die durch eine Sammlung von positiv semidefiniten
Matrizen P0 bis PN minus 1 beschrieben wird, die zur Identität summieren. Wir können diese
Messung dann einfach in eine nicht-destruktive Messung umwandeln, indem wir die Implementierung dieser Messung betrachten, die wir im Kontext von Neymars
Theorem besprochen haben. Wir führen ein neues System Y ein, lassen es mit X über eine unitäre Operation U interagieren und führen dann eine Standardbasis-
messung an y durch. Das System X ist also noch vorhanden, und wir können seinen
Zustand betrachten. Und basierend auf der Analyse, die wir durchgeführt haben, können wir bestimmen, dass der Zustand von X nach der Messung, bedingt
auf das Erhalten eines bestimmten Messergebnisses a, durch eine Dichtematrix gegeben ist, die so aussieht:
In Worten konjugieren wir mit der Quadratwurzel der entsprechenden Messmatrix und
normalisieren dann. Eine weitere Möglichkeit, nicht-destruktive Messungen zu formulieren, die allgemeiner ist, erfolgt in Form von Kraus-
Matrizen von Kanälen, und das ist die Definition von Messungen, die man im bekannten Lehrbuch von Nielsen und
Chuang findet. Angenommen, m0 bis m minus 1 sind quadratische Matrizen, die die
Gleichung erfüllen, die auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird, das heißt, wir könnten diese Matrizen als Kraus-Matrizen betrachten, die einen
Kanal beschreiben. Tatsächlich beschreiben diese Matrizen einen Kanal, aber sie beschreiben auch eine nicht-destruktive Messung,
und so funktioniert es: Wenn ein System in einem gegebenen Zustand Rho gemessen wird, werden zunächst die Ergebniswahrscheinlichkeiten
gegeben durch die auf dem Bildschirm gezeigte Gleichung – jedes Ergebnis tritt mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit auf, die gleich der Spur von Ma *
row * Ma Dagger ist, und wenn das Ergebnis a eingetreten ist, sieht der Zustand des gemessenen
Systems so aus – zerstörungsfreie Messungen dieser Art lassen sich auf ähnliche Weise implementieren wie
das, was wir beim Satz von Neymar hatten, und das überlasse ich dir zum Nachdenken, falls du
möchtest – es ist möglich, das Konzept einer zerstörungsfreien Messung noch weiter zu verallgemeinern, zum Beispiel
gibt es das Konzept eines sogenannten Quanteninstruments, das manchmal recht nützlich ist, aber das werde ich in diesem
Video nicht behandeln. Im letzten Teil der Lektion werde ich kurz zwei Aufgaben besprechen, die mit Messungen zusammenhängen: Quantenzustandsdiskriminierung und Quantenzustandstomographie.
Über beide Konzepte lässt sich sehr viel sagen, und wir werden wirklich nur an der Oberfläche kratzen.
Lass uns also damit beginnen zu klären, worauf sich diese Begriffe beziehen und wie sie sich unterscheiden.
Zuerst die Quantenzustandsdiskriminierung. Die Idee dabei ist, dass wir eine bekannte Sammlung von Quanten-
zuständen eines Systems haben, zusammen mit Wahrscheinlichkeiten, die diesen Zuständen zugeordnet sind. Um es genau zu sagen, nehmen wir an,
dass row 0 bis row M minus 1 Dichtematrizen sind, die mögliche Quantenzustände eines Systems X darstellen, und p 0
bis pN minus 1 sind Wahrscheinlichkeiten, die diesen Zuständen zugeordnet sind. Wenn wir also die Wahrscheinlichkeiten in einem einzigen
Vektor zusammenfassen, erhalten wir einen Wahrscheinlichkeitsvektor. Eine prägnante Ausdrucksweise dafür ist übrigens, dass wir ein Ensemble von Quanten-
zuständen haben. Eine abstrakte Art, wie wir uns die Quantenzustandsdiskriminierung als Aufgabe oder als Problem vorstellen können,
ist: Zunächst wird eine Zahl zwischen 0 und N minus 1 zufällig gemäß den Wahrscheinlichkeiten ausgewählt. Das System X wird dann
im Zustand präpariert, der der zufällig gewählten Zahl entspricht, und das Ziel ist es, durch
eine Messung von X zu bestimmen, welche Zahl gewählt wurde. Wir haben also eine endliche Anzahl von
Alternativen zusammen mit einem Prior, und das Ziel ist es zu bestimmen, welche Alternative tatsächlich eingetreten ist. Bei bestimmten Zuständen und
Wahrscheinlichkeiten kann das einfach sein, und bei anderen ist es möglicherweise nicht möglich, dies ohne eine gewisse Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit zu tun.
Es gibt verschiedene spezifische Fragen, die wir stellen könnten, wie zum Beispiel: Was ist die minimale Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit?
Und wie sieht eine Messung aus, die diese minimale Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit erreicht? Die Quantenzustandstomographie hingegen
ist anders. Hier haben wir einen unbekannten Quantenzustand eines Systems, also gibt es
typischerweise keinen Prior oder irgendwelche Informationen über mögliche Alternativen. Diesmal ist es jedoch nicht eine einzige Kopie des Zustands, die zur Verfügung gestellt wird,
sondern viele unabhängige Kopien werden bereitgestellt, das heißt, für eine möglicherweise große Zahl
n haben wir n identische Systeme X1 bis Xn, die jeweils unabhängig voneinander im Zustand
row präpariert werden, und diesmal ist das Ziel, eine Annäherung an diesen unbekannten Quantenzustand als Dichtematrix durch Messung
der Systeme zu finden. Zusammenfassend also: Bei der Quantenzustandsdiskriminierung haben wir eine einzige Kopie
des Zustands und versuchen, unter einer endlichen Anzahl bekannter Alternativen zu diskriminieren. Bei der Quantenzustandstomographie haben wir viele unabhängige
Kopien eines unbekannten Quantenzustands, und das Ziel ist es, eine Beschreibung dieses Zustands oder zumindest eine brauchbare Annäherung daran zu finden.
Die Quantenzustandsdiskriminierung ist interessant, weil sie eine Art von Situation abstrahiert, die häufig bei
Berechnungen und Kryptografie vorkommt – zum Beispiel, wenn eine Alternative aus einer endlichen Menge von Möglichkeiten eingetreten ist und wir oder jemand anderes versucht,
herauszufinden, welche es war, indem ein Quantensystem gemessen wird. Der einfachste nichttriviale Fall ist
der mit nur zwei Alternativen, das heißt m ist gleich zwei, also besteht die Aufgabe darin, zwischen einem Paar
von Zuständen zu diskriminieren. Dieser Fall stellt sich als im Wesentlichen vollständig gelöstes Problem heraus, vorausgesetzt, das Ziel ist es, die
Wahrscheinlichkeit einer falschen Diskriminierung zu minimieren. Es gibt eine optimale Wahl für eine Messung, und sie wird oft
als Helstrom-Messung bezeichnet. Es handelt sich tatsächlich um eine projektive Messung, und sie kann wie folgt beschrieben werden:
Zunächst betrachten wir die gewichtete Differenz zwischen den beiden Alternativen, also p 0 * row 0 minus P1 * row 1.
Wir multiplizieren also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, jeden der beiden Zustände zu ziehen, mit den Zuständen selbst, und wir nehmen die
Differenz. Das ist eine hermitesche Matrix, weil sie gleich ihrer eigenen konjugiert-transponierten Matrix ist, also hat sie eine Spektral-
zerlegung, und wir wissen insbesondere, dass die Eigenwerte allesamt reelle Zahlen sind. Nehmen wir also an, wir haben eine
Spektralzerlegung in der auf dem Bildschirm gezeigten Form. Was wir als Nächstes tun, ist, die
Eigenwerte in zwei Mengen aufzuteilen, wobei alle positiven Eigenwerte in einer Menge und alle negativen Eigenwerte in
der anderen sind. Genau gesagt nehmen wir S0 als die Menge aller Indizes k, für die der entsprechende Eigenwert Lambda k
nicht-negativ ist, und S1 als die verbleibenden Indizes, also diejenigen, die negativen Eigen-
werten entsprechen. Es spielt eigentlich keine Rolle, welche Menge die Indizes enthält, die etwaigen Null-Eigenwerten entsprechen. Wir treffen hier eine
beliebige Wahl, sie bei minus null einzuschließen, aber es würde keinen Unterschied machen, wenn einige oder alle davon stattdessen in S1 enthalten wären. Was wirklich zählt, ist,
dass wir die positiven und negativen Eigenwerte trennen. Schließlich definieren wir zwei Projektionen Pi
0 und Pi 1, wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. Mit anderen Worten: Pi 0 ist die Projektion auf den
Unterraum, der von den Eigenvektoren aufgespannt wird, die nicht-negativen Eigenwerten entsprechen, und Pi 1 ist die Projektion auf den Unterraum,
der von den Eigenvektoren aufgespannt wird, die negativen Eigenwerten entsprechen. Das sind tatsächlich Projektionen, und
wenn wir sie zusammenzählen, erhalten wir die Identitätsmatrix, weil die Eigenvektoren S 0 bis S N minus 1 eine
Orthonormalbasis bilden. Wenn diese Messung in der vorliegenden Situation durchgeführt wird, das heißt,
der gemessene Zustand ist row 0 mit Wahrscheinlichkeit p 0 und row 1 mit Wahrscheinlichkeit P1, dann stellt sich heraus, dass
die Wahrscheinlichkeit einer korrekten Identifikation eine ziemlich einfache Formel in Abhängigkeit von den Eigenwerten Lambda 0 bis Lambda n minus
1 hat. Ich werde die Details der Berechnung in diesem Video nicht durchgehen. Du kannst den in der Videobeschreibung verlinkten Schriftinhalt konsultieren, falls du
interessiert bist, oder schauen, ob du dich selbst davon überzeugen kannst, dass diese Formel tatsächlich korrekt ist. Wir können das
auch mit einer Matrixnorm ausdrücken, die allgemein als Spur-Norm bezeichnet wird. Die Notation ist ähnlich wie die euklidische Norm für Vektoren,
außer dass wir einen tiefgestellten Index von eins haben, um anzuzeigen, dass es die Spur-Norm ist. Die Spur-Norm ist sehr wichtig und
sehr häufig im Quantum Computing anzutreffen, aber ich werde in dieser Lektion nicht viel mehr darüber sagen. Eine Möglichkeit,
sie für hermitesche Matrizen zu definieren, ist, dass sie die Summe der absoluten Werte der Eigenwerte ist, und du kannst dir
diese zweite Gleichheit so vorstellen, dass sie direkt aus dieser Definition folgt. Die Spur-Norm kann auch
auf andere, allgemeinere Arten definiert werden, und wir werden der Spur-Norm in der nächsten Lektion wieder begegnen. Das ist in der Tat
das Beste, was du tun kannst – diese Messung ist optimal, vorausgesetzt, dein Ziel ist es, die Chance einer korrekten
Dieser Fakt wird manchmal als Helstrom-Holevo-Theorem bezeichnet und manchmal auch einfach als Helstrom-
Theorem bezeichnet. Du kannst diese Messung in Bezug auf die Korrektheitwahrscheinlichkeit nicht übertreffen, und das ist schön, weil
es ein einfaches Rezept für die Messung selbst und eine exakte Formel für die Korrektheitwahrscheinlichkeit in Bezug auf die Spur-
Norm gibt. Die Spur-Norm wird häufig als Maß für den beobachtbaren Unterschied zwischen Dichtematrizen verwendet, und zwar
genau aus diesem Grund. Wenn man vom Spurabstand zwischen Zuständen spricht, meint man damit typischerweise
die Hälfte der Spur-Norm der Differenz zwischen den beiden Dichtematrizen, was hier dem Fall entspricht, in dem p0 und p1 beide gleich 1/2 sind, was
ein natürlicher Fall ist, den man betrachten sollte. Die Quantum-Zustandsunterscheidung für zwei Zustände wird optimal gelöst durch
die Helstrom-Messung, für die wir ein einfaches Rezept und eine einfache Formel für die Korrektheit-
wahrscheinlichkeit haben. Was passiert also, wenn wir unter drei oder mehr Zuständen unterscheiden wollen? In diesem Fall haben wir keine
allgemeine Formel für eine optimale Wahl einer Messung oder einen einfachen Ausdruck für die maximale Wahrscheinlichkeit der
Korrektheit. Es ist jedoch möglich, mit Hilfe eines Computers eine gute Näherung einer optimalen Messung zu finden,
und insbesondere kann das mithilfe einer wirklich faszinierenden und leistungsfähigen Optimierungstechnik geschehen, die als semidefinite Programmierung bekannt ist. Das ist aber nicht
etwas, das du mit einem Stift und einem Blatt Papier durchführen könntest. Wenn andererseits jemand
dir eine Beschreibung einer Messung gibt und behauptet, dass diese Messung für eine Quantum-Zustandsunterscheidungsaufgabe optimal ist, dann ist es
tatsächlich sehr einfach, diese Behauptung entweder zu bestätigen oder zu widerlegen. Das kann mit den sogenannten Holevo-Yuen-
Kennedy-Lax-Bedingungen gemacht werden. Ich werde nicht erklären, was sie sind, in diesem Video, aber es sind einfache Bedingungen, und es ist ziemlich cool,
dass das möglich ist. Hier ist ein Beispiel, das zurück zu den Tetraeder-Zuständen führt,
die wir früher in der Lektion gesehen haben. Angenommen, wir erhalten einen dieser vier Zustände, zufällig ausgewählt mit
Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Viertel für jeden, und unser Ziel ist es, zu bestimmen, welchen Zustand wir erhalten haben. Es ist vielleicht nicht überraschend, aber
die beste Wahl, die du für eine Messung treffen kannst, ist die Tetraeder-Messung. Du kannst das nicht immer
für eine beliebige Sammlung reiner Zustände tun, aber aufgrund der hier vorliegenden Symmetrien funktioniert das
und wir erhalten tatsächlich eine gültige Messung. Mithilfe der Holevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Lax-Bedingungen, die ich erwähnt habe,
vor einigen Momenten, lässt sich ziemlich unkompliziert beweisen, dass dies tatsächlich eine optimale Wahl einer
Messung ist. Konkret geschieht hier Folgendes: Die Messung ist immer mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1/2 korrekt, was
nicht schlecht ist, weil es vier Alternativen gibt. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit einer richtigen Schätzung ist also doppelt so gut wie zufälliges Raten, und es
ist das Beste, was du für diese Zustände erreichen kannst. Jetzt werde ich noch ein bisschen mehr über Quantum-Zustandstomografie sagen,
wo wir viele unabhängige Kopien eines unbekannten Quantum-Zustands haben und das Ziel darin besteht, eine Näherung der Dichtematrix zu finden, die
diesen Zustand beschreibt. Es gibt tatsächlich mehrere verschiedene Varianten dieses Problems, die von deinen Annahmen abhängen, und
insbesondere davon, welche Art von Messungen du erlaubst. Zum Beispiel könnten wir verlangen, dass jedes System einzeln gemessen wird und
die Ergebnisse irgendwie kombiniert werden, um zu einer Beschreibung der Dichtematrix zu gelangen. Oder wir könnten zulassen, dass alle
Systeme zusammen als ein einziges zusammengesetztes System gemessen werden, was theoretisch viel besser ist, aber auch viel
aufwendiger in technischer Hinsicht. Zusätzlich zu den Entscheidungen, die man bei den Messungen trifft, gibt es
auch eine wichtige Überlegung, nämlich wie man eine Beschreibung der Dichtematrix aus den Daten rekonstruiert, die man
aus den Messungen erhält. Ich werde nicht auf Details eingehen; mein Punkt ist lediglich anzudeuten,
dass Quantum-Zustandstomografie wirklich eher ein Oberbegriff ist, der viele verschiedene Varianten umfasst, anstatt ein
einzelnes Verfahren zu sein. Es gibt eine große Menge an Forschung zu diesem Problem, einschließlich einiger recht
jüngerer Durchbruchergebnisse, die die Anzahl der Kopien n mit der Genauigkeit der erreichbaren Näherung verbinden. Es ist und bleibt ein
interessantes und aktives Forschungsgebiet. Um die Lektion abzuschließen, schauen wir uns die Quantum-Zustandstomografie
für qubits an und wie wir sie durchführen können. Angenommen, rho ist eine Dichtematrix, die den Zustand eines
einzelnen qubit beschreibt, und X1 bis Xn sind qubits, die alle unabhängig voneinander im Zustand rho präpariert wurden. Für
diese Diskussion nehmen wir an, dass n groß ist. Was wir tun können, ist die
Systeme in drei ungefähr gleich große Gruppen aufzuteilen. Für die erste Gruppe führen wir eine Messung bezüglich der Plus-
Minus-Basis durch. Für jedes Ergebnis, das Plus entspricht, geben wir die Bewertung Plus eins, und für jedes
Ergebnis, das Minus entspricht, geben wir die Bewertung Minus eins. Eine prägnantere Art, diese Messung zu beschreiben,
ist zu sagen, dass es sich um eine Pauli-X-Messung handelt, weil die Plus- und Minus-Zustände Eigenvektoren der Pauli-X-Matrix sind und die
entsprechenden Eigenwerte Plus eins und Minus eins sind. Das ist tatsächlich auch eine viel gebräuchlichere Beschreibung, und
in der Tat ist der Erwartungswert für die Bewertung gleich der Spur von Sigma X mal rho. Nun erfahren wir nicht unbedingt, was
dieser Erwartungswert ist, aber wenn wir die Bewertungen über viele viele Versuche hinweg mitteln, erhalten wir mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit eine gute
Näherung an diesen Erwartungswert durch das Gesetz der großen Zahlen. Und es gibt einige bekannte statistische Schranken, die wir anwenden können,
wenn wir diese Aussage quantitativer machen wollen. Wir machen etwas Ähnliches mit Sigma Y für das zweite Drittel der
Systeme. Das Einzige, was sich ändert, ist, dass wir die Plus-i- und Minus-i-Zustände verwenden, die Eigenvektoren von Sigma
Y sind, und entsprechend für Sigma Z, für das die Standardbasisvektoren Eigen-
vektoren sind. Schließlich können wir die auf dem Bildschirm gezeigte Formel verwenden, die uns sagt, wie die Koeffizienten sein sollen,
wenn rho als Linearkombination der Pauli-Matrizen geschrieben wird. Indem wir unsere Näherungen für diese Koeffizienten einsetzen
und sie gegebenenfalls ein wenig anpassen, um sicherzustellen, dass wir eine positiv semidefinite Matrix erhalten, bekommen wir eine Näherung an
rho. Natürlich gibt es Details, auf die ich nicht eingegangen bin, wie z. B. die Genauigkeit der Näherung und das Ausmaß der
Sicherheit, die wir erwarten können. Aber hoffentlich gibt dir das eine grundlegende Idee, wie Tomografie an einem
qubit durchgeführt werden kann. Es ist auch möglich, qubit-Tomografie mithilfe der Tetraeder-Messung durchzuführen, und tatsächlich erweist sich das
als ziemlich einfach und elegant, zumindest in mathematischer Hinsicht. Was wir tun können, ist, nur
diese eine Messung allein auf allen unabhängigen Kopien unseres unbekannten Quantum-Zustands durchzuführen. Mithilfe der
bemerkenswerten, hier gezeigten Formel können wir eine Näherung unseres Zustands erstellen, indem wir die Spur von PK mal
rho für jedes K durch den Anteil schätzen, mit dem das entsprechende Messergebnis auftritt. Dies funktioniert wieder nur aufgrund
der perfekten Symmetrien, die wir unter diesen vier Zuständen haben. Es gibt tatsächlich einige wirklich faszinierende ungelöste Probleme, die sich auf Verallgemeinerungen
dieses Ansatzes auf größere Systeme beziehen. Und das ist ein guter Punkt, um die Lektion zu beenden. Danke fürs Zuschauen, und ich
hoffe, du wirst dich mir für die nächste Lektion anschließen, die über Purifikationen und Fidelity handelt. Auf Wiedersehen bis dann.